alright guys this gonna be an awesome
episode we've got Travis here who who's
got a pretty interesting background and
jumped all in and crypto and you
probably have some of the wildest ideas
of what's going on the market and kind
of some of your strategies and stuff so
things gonna be fun so thank you for
coming
glad to be here appreciate thanks for
having me I'm a little under the weather
right now sorry for the hoarse voice but
we're gonna be able to power through it
here you're gonna be just fine alright
so let's go through background right
where'd you grow up kind of where'd you
go to school education and then kind of
what you do pre crypto yeah grew up in
Texas and growing up in Texas I've been
out of college for ten years and nine
and a half of that was in energy
investing right and so you really
strayed really far
got it got out of underground accounting
master's in finance got a school in Oh
eight took the financial crisis in the
face was doing oil and gas M&A for a
couple years out of college in Houston
went to magnetar Capital in 2011 doing
long short energy equities and non
controlled private equity and debt in
the energy space you know to be broad
investment mandate long investment
horizon highly illiquid or totally
illiquid securities I was there from
2011 through the middle of 15 sounds
like the go-go years in oil and gas so
when I joined the energy business was
managing 250 million at magnetar when I
left we're managing 4.6 billion had
pretty massive AUM growth over that
period of time left in the middle of 15
and 1/2 point 72 and New York Seco hedge
fund and I was running a 200 million
dollar long short book there energy and
materials equities a little bit of
commodity a little bit of options and
probably a good way to just easily segue
into crypto here why why why jump in in
crypto yeah so like I'm not a tech guy
I'm not tech investor and I'm not like a
tech person I'm not an early adopter
kind of guy I'm not like a futurist kind
of guy never been like that so first
time I heard about Bitcoin was when Silk
Road got shut down just from a
fascination perspective like look at
these crazy drug dealers and made this
magic internet money to go buy drugs on
the internet that's just wild
I joke I joke around with my mom all the
time where I'm
you know mom it's a good thing that like
I wasn't into drugs when I was a kid so
I like grew up to be like an upstanding
citizen father flipside if I'd have been
into drugs I would have seen Bitcoin
early and I would have bought that [ __ ]
in 2012 but it's true
same thing with video games when I was
growing up my I said the same thing with
my mom too I was like you know mom I'm
kind of glad you didn't make let me play
video games and I was a kid which she
didn't because like now I read more than
probably like 99% of Millennials out
there but then on the flip side it's
like if you grow up playing video games
and like somebody pays $100 for a magic
battle-axe and then you see Bitcoin come
along and you're like this makes all the
sense in the world right
but anyways yes I so like I was reading
about Silk Road just because it's
crazy-- bitcoins part of the story I
probably read like two hours worth of
Bitcoin and about Bitcoin and my
takeaway from that was magic Internet
money there's a math problem the math
problem is really really hard it
controls the supply demand and drug
dealers trust it to use it as money I'm
like that's just nuts right so mal GOx
got hacked if you like not long after
and to me that was like okay this is
like not something I need to pay
attention to yeah because like I don't
have any way to mitigate or pricing the
risk I wake up one morning somebody
stole all my stuff it's like two strikes
yeah and like being there like non sort
of like like like you know hardcore
computer guy I'm like if anybody's gonna
get their stuff so on it's probably me
right so like I'm not into this I didn't
think anything of it fast forwards back
part of 2016 probably starts doing this
thing I started reading more about it
early 17 aetherium and the AI seus
started going crazy I started reading
more about it and I basically came back
like from July 4th break last summer and
fell down the proverbial rabbit hole and
just like started spending all my time
reading about crypto go to the gym
listen crypto podcast go home sit on the
couch in the dark read about crypto to
the wee hours and more and wake up do it
all over again the next day and like I
started stacking out like you know
you're doing the self-study and like I
really like behavioral economics and and
like game theory stuff when I was in
grad school and in grad school I got a
graduate degree in finance and like they
hammer like efficient market hypothesis
like when you're in school and then they
like do a little bit on behavior
and that made no sense to me because it
was like so obvious they're like the
world's not like markets aren't
efficient at all and behavioral
economics is like really what makes
sense because people because of fear and
greed in the context of like economic
decisions humans constantly make
mistakes right and behavioral economics
is kind of the study of that and so I
did like a lot of self-study in school
about that so then I circled back to
crypto and it you know it loops in a lot
of those a lot of those aspects and so I
really got sucked into it I did probably
four or five hundred hours over a couple
month period of time and I went to
senior management out of the blue at the
end of September and I was like look
this blockchain things can be completely
revolutionary so once in generation type
of deal and I don't want to be an equity
long-short portfolio manager anymore I'm
gonna make a career change that's
awesome
alright so let's back up you came from
what I'll call like Wall Street
institutions right so whether it was
energy trading kind of 3.72 and then
point 72 what is that like right so when
you're inside of these organizations how
do they view technology how do they view
kind of these new asset classes when
they kind of pop up and some of them
stay some of them don't just just kind
of talk about you know being a you know
kind of more traditional institution
looking out at you know technology and
new asset classes yes I was kind of
buried down in the like I was just doing
my oil and gas thing my energy thing I
did a decent amount of renewables as
well too so I was like kind of focused
in that one lane so you know look at it
you know it's not looking at anything
outside of oil and gas in energy broadly
yeah yeah inner energy broadly was like
basically my career and like you know I
was like 30 years old and knew about as
much about oil and gas as like any 30
year old yep you're gonna find right
like that was just kind of what I did
and and but but but working in
institutions like that I think one of
the the biggest difference is that I
think I've definitely taken with me you
know as I've moved into crypto investing
full time is I think people that haven't
worked at a hedge fund before think that
it's like an episode of billions where
it's like wolf of Wall Street or it's
like boiler room or something like that
and it's it's actually way less sexy
than that and it's it's it's very very
process-oriented yep and especially
especially a point 72 they just
they just hand like you you become an an
expert and how to build investment
frameworks yep it's a machine yeah it's
a machine and like in the same way that
Henry Ford used to crank out Model T's
like you can crank out attractive
risk-adjusted returns on a repeatable
basis like that and simplistically like
the way I think about it is you build
this framework and then you put a bunch
of process he's inside of the framework
and then you put a bunch of tools you
build a bunch of tools inside of the
process he's to help you execute those
and in the same way that Henry Ford used
to crank out Model T is like you can
just crank alpha like that and it's like
making sausage you can take a shitload
of data you stick it in the sausage
maker you turn the gears and it spits
out profits and you just do it over and
over and over again and there's it's not
but that just so we're clear right like
that's not what people think is
happening what you just said and then to
is that doesn't sound very fun right
because it's not human driven in terms
of out making a duck call left or right
it's much more we spend much time
building what data sets we're gonna do
clean it structure it build the machine
start stuffing the data through there's
not a lot of dependence on the
individual on the individual to have
intuition or you know make mistakes or
make kind of the grand slam call right
yeah so so generally speaking like
humans are like pretty terrible and
investing absolutely absolutely and we
have we have so many biases and we make
tons of mistakes we get tired and yeah
right and so like the term quantum
Mentos got thrown around a lot of point
72 which we've like totally adopted into
Ikki I Asset Management's I gets it the
core of how we've built our investment
business explain what that is yeah so
it's just it's just the intersection of
fundamental and quantitative investing
or like said differently like harnessing
the power of big data to help humans
make investment decisions yep and and
like simplistically it's like you ask
yourself the question like what exactly
is it that a human does better than a
machine when it comes to investing and
like the punchline is it's like not all
that much you know and like this war has
been waging for over a decade now in
traditional asset classes and like the
war is over
dude like the machines have like
fundamentally beat the humans when it
comes to like traditional asset class
investing
just look at the profitability of a
place like Renaissance or jump trading
or or de Shaw right and and it's because
the machines are not only quote unquote
smarter but they have the ability to do
much more analysis more consistently
over a long period of time never get
tired yep never don't make buy there are
no button no biases yep um you know can
crunch an incredible amount of data then
you start layering in like you know
machine learning type of stuff and this
that and the other but but but what the
interesting thing about that you know
the quality mental aspect as you move
into crypto is a machine is only as good
as as the the data that you're feeding
it right like the data is like the food
for the Machine and and if if the if the
investment decisions that that the asset
class is presenting are not like quanta
bowl like they're not able to be sort of
fed into a data stream format then a
machine something be able to make very
good calls yep and like in my opinion
where we are in crypto assets
we're not far enough along and the most
the most foundational pieces of this
ecosystem haven't been put in place yet
and so because of that machine's like
don't do that well in in that that kind
of environment and the data has a lot of
noise in it right and like if I'm trying
to run like a stat ARB strategy and like
a crypto stat ARB strategy in like
September 2018 and I'm like it's a it's
a strategy there was back tested against
price action and like the fall of 2017
we're like what the hell is the fall of
2017 have to do a September 2018 right
it's such a drastically different market
because we're so early and the you know
these we're still having these big
seismic shifts in the way the markets
acting but you know I think what you're
talking about here is there's two issues
one is the quality of the data or the
reliability of the data right so there's
just not that many market cycles to look
at there's not that many kind of great
data sources that you have a high level
of confidence and then the second thing
is there's also a lot of investment
opportunities that there's no data so
early stage investing is really really
hard to quantify
correct right and and and the way the
humans do early stage investing is like
it's like I can't have a view on
aetherium without having a view on a OS
and I can't really have a view on either
two of those things but they have
without having a view on hash score
yep and when you think about that
spectrum of investing machines like not
that great it like like like humans are
really good about taking this really
broad set of data and kind of like
taking this unrelated thing over here
and being like this kind of helps me
think about how this is going to be and
like this other thing over here that's
got nothing to do with crypto at all
kind of like it's like oh I've read
about the history of the Internet and
like it helps inform me and for my
decisions about how I think some of this
is gonna play out like machines don't do
that that well yeah right multi just
dimension like thought processing
decision-making right and so so the way
the way that we've built at a geeky guy
now we've got one systematic strategy
we've got an algorithmic market-making
that's run by piece of technology and
everything else is a human at the end of
the line pulling a trigger but but
you're pulling the trigger you know
you're making investment decisions
informed by information that that like
like like like quantitative type of data
and and you know things that look more
like Clark strategies that help inform
the investment decisions that the human
makes absolutely so let's go back real
quick before you jump full in a crypto
here let's talk about point 72 right
obviously you can only say so much about
it but walk us through like what makes
that place special and what make what
makes that place different from the
repeatability of the returns are able to
drive for you know decades yeah
culture of excellence in incredibly high
caliber people from top to bottom
a stunningly strong operational
framework so that as an investment
professional like the operations of a
hedge fund or the foundation that you're
standing on right and you're trying to
build a house on top of that foundation
and like the foundation of point 72 is
like the most rock-solid slab you could
possibly imagine right I mean there's
like I think there's like a thousand
employees at that firm right and you
know I don't know what the ratio of like
back office the front office is but it's
like 2 to 1 3 to 1 something like that
right so you're standing on this rock
solid foundation you've got every every
resource imaginable at your fingertips
and and
you just it kind of feels like you're
playing pro ball it helps you kind of
elevate your game and you know it's a
great culture in a great environment
because the person next year down the
hallway is now a world class but they
her to eat your lunch right yeah I mean
it's not I feel like people sometimes
think it's it's not it was not like this
like it wasn't like it wasn't like
cutthroat it wasn't like nobody's trying
to like stab somebody else it was not
like that at all you know I can't speak
to like Old Sac like early 2000 sack you
know you hear stories about that
I joined in the middle of 15 a fantastic
place to work
love yeah that's awesome yeah it's great
to when you can leave a place like that
not only say hey I learned a bunch I
worked a great people at great culture
and couldn't speak more highly of it
yeah right
so it says awesome alright so what was
the reaction from you know either people
have point 72 or just Wall Street in
general when you say hey mom short
equity that's great I'm taking a full
jump going into credit though people
excited for you or people think you're
nuts are they trying to follow you down
the rabbit hole what's going on there
probably a deep I'm sure probably not to
my face I'm sure many many many people
thought I was completely insane you know
my mom thought I was crazy right mom
moms always make that you're nuts until
you prove that you're right you're gonna
do they believe me the whole time oh I
read about is this for drug dealers I'm
like that's not not true but you gotta
look out in the future my big my mom's
like a small-town Texas mom grew up in
College Station Texas my mom grew up in
College Station Texas yeah I mom still
lives in consulation Texas so like you
know it's it's um no no but but but but
generally speaking I think people
probably thought I was
it was early yep I didn't I didn't think
it was that much of a risk to me it
didn't feel it didn't feel risky to me
it was there so like again not a tech
investor not a seed stage investor it
wasn't my career path and the only other
time that I felt like I did when I
really know they know crypto and started
understanding it was the first time I
took an uber in Chicago when I was
living in Chicago Chicago got uber uber
it was the second city after San Fran to
get uber signing the first time I took
it uber was like you know January 2011
or 2012 some like 18 months after they
started or something nobody ever heard
of it I don't remember how I heard of it
downloaded the app black car comes and
picks me up from my apartment to go to a
store Johnson all this store I'm staying
on sidewalk drives away I'll never
forget it and I remember I was like that
is going to change everything
that was positive about it positive
about it and sure enough like you know
you watch what Hoover did obviously over
the coming years and I used to joke
around like the day I took I took that
uber I should have just quit magnetar
and walked in ubers office and been like
you know I'll push Microsoft Excel for
you like I'll do biz dad whatever just
sign pay me in stock right would have
been a good career move Beyonce's got a
gun a line maybe inequity yeah yeah
exactly right and I would have been
probably the the 25th dude you know
whatever it Oberer and like that would
have been a nice move only other time in
my life I felt like that was when I
really understood crypto and I dug into
it and I just didn't have any doubt in
my mind that this thing was going to
completely change everything and
specifically I'm super unsure about how
that's gonna happen it's just I'm
directionally broadly highly convicted
as bullish as you can be and I was like
it felt like just like a great bet to go
make in terms of like betting my career
on it yeah yeah it's this idea of
confident in the trend details to be
determined yeah right yeah yeah so what
it's like what I tell people is like
there's a nonzero chance that Bitcoin
could be Netscape and aetherium could be
Alta Vista and we haven't seen Google we
haven't seen Facebook Amazon Netflix
uber yet and there's a nonzero chance to
Bitcoin go go be the global immutable
decentralized store value in the world
reserve currency and one BTC could be
worth four hundred fifty K or two
million or three million or pick a
number and everything in between
yep and I'm really not sure about
specifically how that's gonna play out
and so everything the way we've built a
key guy is to have malleability in our
mandate and have a clear look into how
this thing is going to play out so that
you can make investment decisions
accordingly and it's like you just go
with the strong opinions weakly held
thing right
you you you you you intake as much
information as possible you you assess
that information you analyze it you make
investment decisions based on it and
what something new comes along you
change your mind dude you change your
mind how do you do that there right so
you've got conviction on something you
got the strong opinion right you know
that it's loosely held but but one of
the things that you look at that would
change your mind right is it data is it
conversations as a god like what are you
looking at that that allows you to
change your mind
and I'm at necessary on a dime but but
pretty quickly to you know go after a
different opportunity it's a great
question it's so many things yeah it's
so many things I mean I'm coming from
from the world that I came from I do
latch on to any kind of data that I can
it's pretty natural to me probably done
more work in that then certainly not
everybody like hats off like a Nick
Carter right like the guy's a beast with
all that stuff and and you know Brendan
Bernstein's great a lot of those guys
but but I definitely have a tendency to
just take that like anything I can
quantify let me try and quantify it and
maybe I can't draw an investment
decision from it but let me at least
have it well give me as many tools in my
tool shed as I can get right and then
this space is very big on narrative
investing right so you kind of track
these narratives and start thinking
through that and you and you have to
understand how these things are
developing like a year ago we're talking
about big like like we're gonna use it
Bitcoin to buy a cup of coffee remember
that those a year ago right oh that's
what we're gonna use a Bitcoin for okay
got it
and then you're just like like as people
realize that wasn't gonna happen anytime
soon as like I know it's digital gold
it's difficult right
I don't know Austrian economics and I
get it right and like and I get that and
it's like you know aetherium you know
world's computer or right on to destroy
his computer blah blah this and the
other Oh done scale oh [ __ ]
what else can we use are oh oh yeah but
it's gonna scale cuz we got we got
Casper coming way we know how Casper is
not close oh no we can say the world's
electricity cuz we're gonna go pretty
fast eight right right all right but but
but even from the very beginning like
when I really went down the rabbit hole
just because I am a really cautious guy
like as a because a investor and as a
human I'm cautious like I'd never go
skydiving or you like I'm not
not about that life whatsoever and as an
investor I'm like I'm very like cautious
in the way that I invest is well - and
so the hundreds of hours that I spent in
the beginning before I quit my job a lot
of that time I spent looking at all the
problems in this ecosystem I was like
why is this thing not gonna work wise
and not gonna work wise and not gonna
work and I was looking at you know proof
of work like this is obviously not gonna
work on a large scale and then you look
at this proof of stake thing I'm like
but it's not as secure but then you
start really digging into it and like a
lot of the cryptography like people have
been doing proof of stake as a concept
in cryptography has been around since
the 90s like it's not a brand new
concept a lot of this cryptography a
cyclic grasp do people were doing that
work in like the 70s right now you're
just trying to weave it into computer
science and so like that gives you a
little bit of comfort that that like
you're not just like trying to pull this
stuff out of thin air well it's what
makes it so interesting to the smart
people in the world right it is it is
the true like polymath type environment
where you gotta have knowledge and some
kind of experience of respective from a
whole bunch of different disciplines and
you pull them together and it's not just
let me pull you know economics computer
science geopolitics and like the history
of money on an even basis actually I
only pulled 10% from you know economics
and 50% from psychology in 30 whatever
and so how do you build that into a
skill set that then not only helps you
understand it but then you can deploy
capital against yeah right and and and
sometimes those two things actually
aren't the same and I think that's part
of what draws so many smart people into
the space is there's problems that need
to be solved and they're not solve yet
they may never get soft really may get
solved tomorrow right and it's it's the
puzzle of all puzzles right because
there are there are so many aspects to
it and and yeah that's why I mean gives
you so much to chew on right and if you
figure it out obviously from an economic
incentive perspective right like if you
if you get it right like you're gonna
get a game yeah yeah you're gonna get
paid on that so and and like you know
not to get like cheesy but like the
societal aspect of it as well - was
super important to me because like a key
guy so let's talk about what you're
doing to
and kind of where the name came from
yeah yeah so a key guy ancient Japanese
concept that means a reason for being
super old where it's like 1200 year old
where there's books and stuff written
about it if you google iki guy it's
there you see this like Venn diagram and
the Venn diagrams like what you could
what you're good at what you like to do
what you deserve to be paid for and what
the world needs and I just came across
the concept randomly like a year ago
and I really liked it and like to be
honest with you is I had a career and
had fun investing right and I liked
doing it I was pretty good at it
I made a fine living doing it but like
the world doesn't need another hedge
fund manager right
the world didn't get another hedge fund
manager the world's gonna be just fine
and some people would argue we could
lose a couple of billion and be just
fine right but like but the world needs
this technology and and in the
technology is a platform to go affect
societal change for the good and like
I'm much more of a realist than I am
like you know that you run across a lot
like techno utopians you know the type
of person in this space lot of dudes
right but but but I'm much more of a
realist but what I saw was society
starting to recoil from these
monopolistic abuses of power at various
different levels and you start seeing
these trends right it's like brexit
Donald Trump getting into office you
know hyperinflation NSA's NSA stuff like
Facebook election ads right black lives
matter
Harvey Weinstein Cambridge analytical
like there's a common theme that runs
across all that and you just have to
look at it all the surveys of
Millennials Millennials are the
generation they have a deep distrust of
governments large financial institutions
large technology companies right like
it's like Facebook takes your dad and
they do shitty stuff with it Google
takes your dad and like they do they
like don't keep it safe right and like
Apple like takes your data and like you
know like makes these other products and
they hook you in and they like box other
people out so it's like it's pretty
monopolistic the way they do stuff and
like stuff gets hacked all its equifax
right like what I mean look if you are
under the age of 40 you might as well
just admit or give in to the idea
that your data your personal financial
data and your in your actual personal
data is floating around on the internet
somewhere and if somebody's got money
they can buy it fax fax you can get you
can get like 500 credit card numbers for
like $5 on the internet like on like
whatever black market stuff but but you
know you know you look at you look at
you look at just Millennials in general
and the same way that that polls are
showing you how much that that distrust
is the older you are the less you think
Bitcoin makes sense the more you think
gold makes sense the younger you are the
more you think Bitcoin makes sense the
less you think gold makes sense so you
fast forward a couple decades from now
and millennial like we're all like you
know 50 and like what do you like what
do you really think is gonna happen yeah
I mean look I we go and talk these
institution that was all time right and
I always tell them I said listen if you
if you don't take anything else from
this conversation understand that people
under the age of 35 have an amount of
their net worth in this asset class that
would make you just you just absolutely
disgusted yeah right I'm talking mid
double digits in many cases where we're
talking you know 35 40 50 sometimes even
70 80 % of their net worth their total
net worth is tied up in digital assets
now some of it is they put a little bit
in and it exploded in value and so it
grew but I also know a lot of people
were taking you know 50 60 70 % of their
salary yeah and they're they're still
buying yeah right and they just it's a
store value it's a medium of exchange
it's the new stocks that you know the
commodity it makes sense it makes sense
it just resonates and problems are gonna
get solved the hiccups with the industry
are solvable hiccups absolutely and also
it's the opportunity cost right so you
know you know if you think of your if
your institution you got a hit you're 6
to 8 percent you know kind of actuary
assumed rate of return in order to pay
out the millions of people who are
depending on you if you're an endowment
for education or you're a pension for
retirements all the stuff you're not
hitting that today in most cases right
well if you can't hit six to eight
percent where do you go yeah
uncorrelated digital assets is one area
to look and so money we're saying even
if I could hit six to eight percent in
the public markets debt real estate all
stuff that's not interesting to me I can
take a bunch of risk I'm young so where
do they go they go for the six seven
hundred eight hundred percent annualized
returns that they just saw and so
they're gonna continue to do that yeah
right and so it's all of these forces at
work that
drive a huge amount of capital from a
very specific demographic into digital
assets
everyone's gonna fall they have to fall
Yeah right it may take longer but it's
gonna happen yeah we internally we talk
about it it's like musical chairs and
sovereigns they have their game of
musical chairs that they're playing and
like institutional investors right like
endowments state state pension funds
they plans things like that it's like a
game of musical chairs and like Bitcoin
just stopped music right or they're in
the bitcoins in the process of stopping
the music and like nobody's really
sitting down yeah you hear whispers
right like there's some people in the
Middle East buying like a lot of Bitcoin
right you hear that right like there's
like you hear whispers about stuff from
a sovereign perspective like we know
there's definitely some like large
financial institutions that are
definitely sniffing around in like you
know maybe got a little exposure here a
little exposure there and it's like you
know maybe something crazy happens like
like Italy gets kicked out of the EU
writer and like the European Union
starts looking like it's like
questionable which is like nada nada
there's non zero that's a totally non
zero chance over the next couple years
totally non zero chance and then all of
a sudden it's like you hear that like
the Swiss sovereign wealth fund like
it's got their along some Bitcoin right
so now now Switzerland just sat down
right in there and there's not that many
chairs right if you got 20 you got 21
million Bitcoin a couple million of them
are lost right and only 17 million a bit
mined right yeah and all of a sudden it
starts looking like it's it's what we're
talking about it's irresponsible to not
be involved and the reflexivity in the
price action when when some of that
stuff starts catching on the potential I
mean it's gonna be breathtaking
you know if it's some of that stuff look
we actively tell these institutions
right it's the best performing asset
class over the last five years if you
add 1% of digital asset exposure into a
global 60/40 portfolio the returns go up
by you know anywhere between 100 to 300
basis points depending what it was and
the standard deviation of risk stays
about the same and you get a
double-digit increase in the Sharpe
ratio yeah the second that you start
looking at that where else can you get
that yeah right and so it's not about
how high can they go it's actually about
managing risk of your overall portfolio
and if you have zero exposure to the
asset class you
have to immediately get off 0 yeah right
and we literally I mean you can imagine
talking to a you know 50 60 year-old cio
who manages billions of dollars and
don't get off zero right that's the
message right now and I think to your
point there's people who are starting to
do it but when when it actually kind of
the dam burst right watch out right
totally right alright so let's talk
about some of the things that are
happening kind of pre before that
happening right so right now I know that
you're you've got some real interesting
thoughts around like bit max and some of
these markets that are already here that
people already using today like what do
you think is so interesting about those
types of companies and markets that are
being built yeah and so so earlier
you're talking about like how do I
change my mind I mean I mean part of it
is is you create all these processes
around in taking every aspect of
information that you can about the the
development of the space and assessing
that information and putting it into a
you know a broader kind of mosaic
framework to help make investment
decisions and a lot of that is just
thinking about market structure and and
year-to-date
you know the two the two 800-pound
gorillas that have shown up from a
market structure perspective year today
it is is pit mechs and the Asian
algorithmic market maker and let's go it
makes first so explain what is bit mix
why why do you think it's the gorilla
yeah yeah so bit mix is a non license
exchange or unregulated exchange they
trade a synthetic Bitcoin future you
fund only in Bitcoin you can get up to a
hundred X leverage long or short on
Bitcoin it's been around for a few years
wasn't that popular especially in 2017
when everybody was going [ __ ] coin
hunting on crypto Pia and COO coin and
Finance but as the markets woken up here
to date and realize that all that
stuff's worth zero bit Mex has become
you know I mean I think they've got like
a 2 or 3 times more volume than like the
number to exchange and you can get
massive leverage on it so okay so we're
do one side about this leverage things I
don't think a lot of people understand
one
what is leverage and how do people use
leverage in a positive manner right and
then what can that do the market on the
negative side as well yeah yeah so so
specifically in the context a bit mechs
like if I put if I put one Bitcoin long
with a hundred X leverage that means I'm
getting returns like a long 100 Bitcoin
so you you take out of your wallet or
your portfolio using one Bitcoin which
is whatever six seven thousand dollars
okay and you put it down and say I'm
going long I think it's gonna continue
to go up in value as the bed right but
you're getting credit for actually
having put down a hundred bitcoins and
saying these hundred are gonna go up why
does bit mix do that because humans love
to gamble all right yeah and so what is
the economic benefit to you when you put
this 100x leverage on and what is the
potential of negative side effect right
so so if you if the price goes up if
you're right right then you're
generating returns like your long a
hundred Bitcoin only putting up one
Bitcoin worth of risk however great risk
return profile however specifically on
like the hundred at the hundred x
example the way the margin works is it
doesn't have the way normal margin works
like in tradition like in the real world
it's a function of how much money you
have in your account and as long as you
have money in your account you continue
to make like at the end of day you make
there's margin calls and you you like
make it up if you're losing money every
day I kind of stay even your account you
be asleep a down the margin you can keep
your losses
right and you can stay in a position
forever in the way it works at bit mix
is though the leverage is only specific
to that individual trade so if you have
a 100 X leverage on you lose 1% you
automatically get stopped out and you
look and you lose the one Bitcoin that
you put up or if you're long 25-person
you know if you're long like 25 X
leverage then you get stopped out it
like you know 375 s whatever they're not
the number is right yeah we're great
deal for bit max oh yeah right Arthur
hey his name I mean just just absolute
savage right and just printing money one
of most savage guys in this space period
yep complete complete Macho Man Randy
Savage look and we talked about it
before
I mean the part that I love is not only
that he's created these products and
he's got him out there people are using
him but but he is out pounding the table
saying we have them right so he's on
Twitter and he's saying look you you you
know good traders go both ways
yeah right up and down let's see what
you got yeah and and he introduced you
know so he started rolling out new new
instruments right so you got directional
eath exposure you have up to 50 X
leverage on aetherium and you get paid
in Bitcoin you don't get paid in theory
and if you if you make money on the
short side you get paid in Bitcoin so
your shortened a theory and making money
in Bitcoin same thing which most of the
shorts love yeah of course right you can
you can now go long short on ripple Tron
Bitcoin cash yose Cardno
and with varying up to 20x leverage on
some of them 50x on on others and and
quantitatively listing on bit Mex has
been the kiss of death year to date so I
was just gonna ask you what do you think
this is doing to the market well well
well what it's done is it is given a
venue to now have true price discovery
to two-way price discovery because
previously you could only go long you
could short on bit the necks but you
didn't have enough liquidity and now
there's there's a ton of liquidity on on
bit necks right now so you can really
express it except which I'm glad you
brought this up it's the worst kind of
liquidity well because its its liquidity
except there's extremely sophisticated
quantitative investors Wall Street guys
like like like your old world yeah yeah
they're like not specifically point 72
but like those types of people you'd
like those types of folks right like the
best in the business and from a
quantitative perspective you know I
don't want to name names one of them
rhymes with lump the other one arrives
with de raw so these guys so these guys
are doing liquidity modeling and on on
bit Mex and the way that works is they
call the network three times a second
and by calling a network three times a
second they're pulling down very minut
volume data
and then I'm not a hundred percent sure
but I think how they do it is they can
see where the price gets executed
relative to the specific volume at that
moment relative to the bid-ask I think
they can back into where the amount of
leverage that was put on for that
specific trade at that specific moment
three times a second Wow and then
they're able to then map out where the
stops are and then they you can map this
out and they see where a bunch of stops
start getting stacked up on top of each
other and put on the gas right and
there's just like a Jenga game except
except these really sophisticated quads
are the only ones that can see the Ginga
tower everybody else just thinks it's
like oh we're just there's no there's no
blocks being pulled out yet but they see
the whole thing and then when they see
all these stops that are that are could
potentially get pushed over then all
they got to do is go and give the Ginga
pile a little nudge and then you run
through all those stops or you in and
and so if you just look at the price
action over the last handful of months
like it's so obvious they'd like that's
the market structure that's going on and
and that's when you're seeing it if
you're a retail investor you're seeing a
immediate within seconds four hundred
price jump right yeah that's right and
they and everybody gets stopped out and
then also bit mix bit mix works just
fine until you really need it to work
and that it doesn't work anymore because
gets shut down because gets there's too
many people trying to trade and then all
these stops get run out and then the
really smart guys take all the really
the retail guys money so that's a that's
that's terrible for the long-term health
of the ecosystem which is why I wanted
to talk about it today because it's
really like like you know those vines
that wrap around the tree and they kill
the tree if you let the vines sit there
long enough like that seems like exactly
what like that type of stuff is
happening right now and so it's it's
really to the detriment of the long-term
health of the ecosystem I'm guessing
that it's it's untenable in the medium
term and something's gonna happen I
don't know what's gonna happen but is it
more so like a regulatory type solution
or is it just that more people come into
the space that are smart and then they
all kind of start commoditizing some of
this and you get some relief well the
way that I think about it is like if the
client is the bully and like the retail
guys like like the small kid in school
like every day the small kids like
walking into school and getting punched
in the gut by the bully and he gets his
lunch money still
and after a while like you just stopped
going that way right and like that's
exactly what's gonna have like there's
gonna clear out all all the retail money
it's just gonna be like qua non quant
crime which I think it's like oh this
has all happened in traditional asset
classes Quan Quan crime has been
happening for like a decade now in
traditional asset classes and so so
that's a problem and the other thing I
want to talk about is is Asian algorithm
market making which is like the other
800-pound gorilla which is like also the
vine that's wrapped around the tree
that's like gonna kill the tree if you
let it keep going all right so let's
let's start with just what is that yeah
yeah so so I don't mind like let's go
let's get the names let's see here this
one rhymes with left free he yeah there
you go
all right so so we there's a couple of
them there's about ten big boys yeah
it's about ten big boys and they don't
sit in the United States yep they're not
United States citizens their businesses
aren't domiciled in the United States so
they're out of the long arm of the reach
the long reach of US regulators they've
got some protections which which means
which means that they you really can do
whatever you want to and like it's not
illegal and like we call it got cuffs on
this yeah it's called we call a [ __ ]
all right it's not illegal it's it's
[ __ ] and and and [ __ ] is a
combination of manipulation and it's
it's like morally it's like morally it's
stuff that you just wouldn't do all
right
and like morals is a cultural thing yep
so like I'm not trying to like look I
got a different set of cultural values
and me and like I mean if I was a
Chinese guy that like you lived in China
my whole life and like I could start
printing money like that like I might do
it - I don't know but like you could
view it as actually hey I'm getting back
at you you guys been messing with us for
you know decades whatever right like
yeah but but but like that's what's
happening and so like if it's one of the
main reasons why the the Asian ico
market right now as we sit here today
has decoupled so much from the u.s. ico
market us I see a market is like almost
ground to a halt right yeah
yeah like a small percentage of deals
that you had earlier this year well it's
almost like the the bully you know
student example you gave earlier it's
like the teacher showed up in the
hallway right it's like hey knock knock
off all the [ __ ] yeah exactly that's a
great point that's always happening in
the US
market so now you've got like like Asian
ICO XYZ token they go raise like forty
million dollars in their ICO they take
like ten percent of the tokens and they
just give them to the algorithm a market
maker not only they give it to them they
also give them like six million bucks
and eath two and then they get a coin
listed on an exchange and then they
start wash trading based are washed
rating back and forth with each other
all right so most people are going to
know what washed rating is right let's
start from kind of the beginning of if
you're one of these tokens you did your
IC o---- when you get listed on an
exchange any liquidity right so there's
a couple ways to get liquidity on you
know in your token or kind of the
trading volume on a daily basis one of
them is wash trading what is that yeah
so that's you have it you have multiple
accounts set up on the same exchange and
your buying and selling to yourself from
yourself so you own all the exchanges or
all the accounts on the exchange that
are doing the high-volume trading for
the day yeah yeah yeah that's right
you're just executing trades amongst
yourself with multiple multiple accounts
yep internet gives the illusion you know
there's volume there's real buying and
selling that's happening and by the way
they're just driving price like you're
literally just like manipulating price
to get to a certain level and these guys
will contractually guarantee a volume
and contractually guarantee a market
price like like in writing again it's
not illegal over there so it's like it's
fine
they get paid hella money to do to do
this and then even crazier than that
they'll get in like the they use like
WeChat over there we use telegram right
and everybody's talking about it so in
there we chat groups and they're
listening all the technical indicators
like ta guys they're talking about the
different indicators that are like like
in this particular crypto and they
listen whatever people are talking about
and then they just start painting a
specific technical indicator so they
call here's a bull flag oh we got a bull
flag coming up oh we got a you know
whatever a rising wedge like this that
and the other any but it really is a
it's a psyche it's psychological warfare
against retail investors yeah it could
be terrible yeah it's it is the vine
around the tree that it will poison the
tree it is to the detriment of the
health of this ecosystem as a whole now
the scary thing is that the exchanges
are in on it
CZ is in on it right there they're in on
it because in a bear market they got to
have these
I need the volume they got to have them
and they if if you know XYZ token gets
listed and they don't have an agent and
they don't have an Asian algorithm a
market maker on the back end then the
token there's a good chance it's gonna
crash as soon as it gets listed because
the private retail investors that got
into eighty ninety five percent discount
don't be they're dumping immediately but
the crazy thing is is you know you're
given ten percent of the tokens away and
you're given like you know whatever ten
percent of the raised way to catch the
volume on the back end you see how like
not good that is right and and how
untenable that is and like not healthy
for the overall like long term what
would it also it is serving the number
one use case for crypto today which is
speculation yeah right I mean that's
literally what is happening here is
they're they're taking tokens and
they're creating new speculation tools
or products and people are using them
right for speculation not for the
adoption that actually drives long
serves long term sustainability right
and and and the individuals or the
entities most likely to make a profit
from from that situation are the ones
that are the most sophisticated the ones
most likely to lose money and just like
like the more retailers you are the more
you're guaranteed to lose money in this
process which is just not good I'm I am
hoping and I don't know maybe cz you're
gonna hear this well tweet ole tweeted
to see like you you homies was easy he
retweets me a lot we've never really
talked to you and I hope you here's this
when we get out of this bear market
which I don't know when it's gonna be
but like you got to cut the [ __ ] man
like you have to self-regulate you have
to self-regulate and you got it you got
this wash Trading the the price
manipulation painting TA signals like
you can't have that and here's the one
thing though that that I think is really
interesting so the one the one thing
that I'll say to defend some of them
right because I think that you're
probably right in that a lot of this is
going on across exchanges right I think
that it's just what they believe whether
the right or not needs to happen for the
volume to be there bare market all that
kind of stuff right so let's just put
all that in a box and set it aside for
example or for a second the one thing
though that I think encourages me that
that won't be the long term strategy is
all the tokenize security stuff right so
you start to see a bunch of these guys
saying
look the the utility token stop the
speculation it's gonna keep happening
we're making a bunch of money today but
long term regulators are gonna step in
in different jurisdictions they're gonna
draw the rules and we're gonna play by
the rules and so they say oh token high
securities I don't know but right and I
could be wrong on this I don't know if
they're gonna be able to do a lot of
that wash trading etc into highly
regulated tokenized securities the world
like they can do it now they get away
with a little bit of it but you know
that gives me hope that there's kind of
a light at the end of the tunnel and
token of securities will actually make
this a much more kind of traditional
market I agree with that yeah and none
of that stuff can happen like you can't
wash straight on kanji decks right yeah
you can't wash straight on bit Finex
and they've got all kinds of technology
to catch you yep and like if you do just
a little bit of it they will kick you
off for sure so like iki guys so we have
an algorithmic market making strategy
that makes you know makes money off by
buy and sell spreads and very liquid
tokens and we also provide us regulatory
compliant algorithmic market making as a
service to tokens so if you want to do
it like in a regulatory compliant way
and it's just buy and sell it's just a
20 for it right where the 7-eleven we're
open 24 hours a day seven days a week
nice piece of technology that's sitting
there and if anybody wants to come by or
come sell we've got a piece of
technology that can easily execute those
types of things and you know you're not
manipulating price you're not doing loss
trade and you're obviously not painting
any kind of like TA signals or anything
like that because you do need a
liquidity provider I mean look at
traditional asset classes they have I
mean it's an it's an enormous business
nor liquidity providers is like a
multibillion-dollar many many many
billion dollar a year business and so
that's not gonna go away
you just need to do it in a manner that
doesn't doesn't bend over the retail
investor right absolutely
I completely agree with that all right
so let's let's switch first I can talk
about the valuation of digital assets
right you know today I think that
there's really much more information
much more kind of theory around how do
we actually use data and fundamentals to
value individual assets
how are you guys thinking about this
where do you think we are in terms of
the the maturation of the valuation
methodology for digital assets yes this
is a topic near and dear to my heart
like I
I pretty much stopped doing anything
other than valuing stuff when I was like
19 years old like first up level finance
class like my junior year in college
like it's pretty much all I've done
since then done in a bunch of different
asset classes done in super liquid stuff
done in and completely illiquid stuff up
and down the capital structure and so
like when I came into this space it was
incredible to me to see how early it was
in thinking about like if I buy a crypto
today am I paying a lot or a little for
it I buy Bitcoin today my pain a lot or
a little
yeah well the price is sixty five
hundred dollars well that doesn't tell
you if I'm paying a lot or a little for
it right that's just our price when I
think about like back to my old good
career path like if I'm if I want to buy
a share of ExxonMobil today am I paying
a lot or a little for a share of
ExxonMobil
I've got like 30 different tools in the
tool shed to help me understand whether
or not in the way that you're coming to
that conclusion traditional markets or
in the digital asset world is what is
the price and what is the value of the
actual asset and is it above or below
the value of the asset buy something
yeah price is not value yep yeah price
is what you can buy it for today but it
but but you need some sort of relative
valuation framework to think about is
this a lot is this am I paying a lot you
know relative to historical am I paying
a lot relative to other assets so you
start needing to have this like you know
a homogenized framework to start
thinking about these kinds of things and
in traditional asset classes there's all
sorts of stuff right I got like assets
you know metrics based on assets and
revenues and cash flows and earnings and
growth in like you know if I want to buy
a share of ExxonMobil like you know I
can take like my oil price assumption
plug it into my model there's like
multi-factor models where where you
start breaking a part of stock in like
it's like you know you know this stock
is like a function of like it's a
momentum stock or a value stock or it
has high leverage or like you know
there's all kinds of different valuation
metrics and then like I stepped in this
asset class and and I've read like you
know probably 80 90 percent of the
things that have been written about
valuation in crypto period like I've
read the vast majority of it
nothing has been written about about
crypto asset valuation that's older than
like eighteen months old which is crazy
right because like Benjamin Graham wrote
the intelligent investor in like 1949 or
something still one of the most like
important books on equities investing
period and when people look at PE ratios
for the S&P 500 you look at them like
6070 years back in time and you're
telling me nobody's written anything
that's older than 18 months old talking
about crypto asset valuation so I so I
started being like well like how do we
think about about value in this asset
class you think it's important to have
the traditional market valuation
understanding going into the asset class
or do you think that there's value in
people not having that historical
context I mean I'm biased but all right
so what do you think I mean these are
these are public instruments and they
trade every day yep and I wake up every
morning and I can buy or sell my entire
universe every day and not being
involved in a specific name on the long
or the short side is in it of itself a
decision right that's a position to not
be involved if I'm a tech guy like I'm
like a tech bro out of the Bay Area it's
like a developer or whatever like I have
no understanding of that framework what
percentage of people trading crypto do
you think you've read the intelligent
investor way less than 1% right less
than 1% yeah yeah you know maybe I don't
know what percent maybe and even and
even and look god bless those guys yep
because they had the vision for this
[ __ ] that I didn't have like I was there
I was like slangin long short energy
equities when these guys were like all
in their stuff so like I really
appreciate that yep
different skill set different but yeah
and same thing with the VC guys right
like I really appreciate that
perspective as well too but like the way
VCS invest is you make 10 bets 7 of them
go to 0 the 8th one breaks even 9th when
you make 2 or 3 times your money the
10th when you make 50 to 100 times your
money the best the best VC firms in the
world they do like one and a half
standard deviations better than that
like the shitty VC firms do like one and
a half standard deviations worse than
that but like that's a VC math right and
it takes 3 to 10 years for that cycle to
play out so just imagine the skill set
that you get investing in that type of
world versus investing like I wake up
every morning I can buy and sell my
entire universe and like and you have
data to you know
and you have data to drive decisions
whereas a lot of the venture stuff
especially early stage you're betting on
people you're using intuition you're
going after a whole different set of
criteria on a yes/no decision versus
really kind of daily liquidity
data-driven you know liquid market right
yeah and so and so that all feels feels
comfortable to me and so I started
looking around for how to think about
crypto asset valuation and people like
to use like total addressable markets
and easy one right like Gold's like
seven and three-quarters trillion
dollars so if Bitcoin gets half of that
it's like seven hundred and seventy five
billion that's up like whatever like
five five times from here or more yeah
from big yeah yeah so like that feels
like okay that's like kind of helpful
and then and then people started
realizing that network value should be a
function of network activity and in like
transactions per day active wallet
addresses even things like community
vibrancy metrics which is what you know
it's like github
you know github commits github stars
lines of code written line you know net
aligns deleted people were looking at
like slack channel members for a while
Telegram members that it's it's way too
easy to game that and there's noise in
all this stuff which is like a big
problem with it right because it's not
again back to like our quantum mental
approach and trying to take in as many
different sort you got to use all these
different tools in the tool shed so it's
like I can't go hang my hat on like oh
I've got a strategy I just wake up every
morning and like if there aren't any if
there weren't enough transactions on the
Bitcoin network yesterday I'm sure like
it doesn't work like that right yeah but
it gives you something to try and help
frame the overall mosaic approach to
evaluation so here's a controversial
thought for you I'm biased because I
come out of this world but I actually
think that a group of people who have
the best skillset for investing and
trading in in the crypto asset world is
people who worked at on growth teams at
large technology companies because
they're used to the multidisciplinary
approach around statistics psychology
user interface community grow you know
all the network effects all this stuff
and they they brought together to drive
growth of these assets so there was no
price attached right so we hard to say
you know Facebook or Twitter or whatever
hey our network
value is X and here is dr. price there's
none of that going on but I think that
the jump from that basic understanding
to what price should do is really easy
yeah or does somebody who doesn't have
that that understanding from a ground
perspective completely agree glad you
brought it up because I want to unpack
that because like what your background
is is boots on the ground experience of
Metcalfe's law right which which people
have taken them Metcalfe's and try to
apply to crypto asset valuation a lot
and and there's some truth there and
there's also a lot of lies in there as
well
right but by taking that one principle
and trying to apply it yeah well true
true Metcalfe's which is which is the
value of a telecommunications network is
directly proportional to the square of
the number of users if true modified
Metcalfe's has never been shown to
accurately describe the value of
anything but in 2013 I don't know if
you've read this paper or not in 2013
some guys came out I think Metcalfe and
Bob Metcalfe himself was actually
involved in this they put out a paper
either 13 or 15 where they they
introduced this modified Metcalf concept
called the net ID function okay which is
an s-curve shape which makes total sense
right because it's gonna you're gonna
like level out right because like if
I've got five telephones in the world
and you add a six telephone the amount
of value that went up is totally
different than if I've got a billion
telephones and I add the billion in
first telephone totally different right
so it's this S curve metalloid function
so so so this academic paper introduced
the net election and then which instead
of being true Metcalfe's it takes it
introduces this virality factor concept
and then introduces like the percentage
it adjusts it for the percentage of
users that have adopted relative to the
total number of users that could adopt
and it introduces this S curve and then
they showed the net weight function to
accurately fit the number of monthly
active users on Facebook and ten sent to
Facebook and ten cents revenue growth
and that's yeah that's super dope right
and you work obviously front lines for
that right
and so so so then that got super
interesting in terms of thing about
crypto asset valuation because that
feels like crypto yeah right part of it
too is not just where are we today in
terms of what percentage of people are
using something for compared to the
amount of people who could use it right
so kind of addressable market and actual
users but also a lot of things that
don't get talked around crypto is like
what's like the the k coefficient right
right and things were like you know
every person who starts to use Bitcoin
how many other people can they bring
into the system it's really hard to
quantify that hard right and so there's
some level of virality there right and
as much as like joke around on Twitter
about like the virus is spreading that's
really where it came from hundred
percent was this idea that if I tell you
about Bitcoin and I tell three other
friends some percentage of you are going
to say this is stupid some percentage of
like I'm all-in and I'm gonna go be the
next like Kryptonian artist and some
group says I want to learn more right
right and so like what is that growth
look like as more and more people learn
this and what we find is like it really
does capture the mental energy and
attention of a whole demographic of
people it can't be stopped you cannot
kill this yeah yeah so so the
introduction of a crypto asset what it
does is it allows for network effect to
take hold in a completely different way
than you've ever experienced in any
other kind of kind of instrument or
anything like that before because in
traditional network effect you've got
you know which is you know
simplistically any technology that
derives a significant portion of its
value from from from Network effect it's
just the more people that come to it the
more the value goes up right and each
additional user makes it you know X
percentage more valuable as a network
overall yeah yeah that's right and and
it's an s-curve right and you get to a
point where you hit critical mass where
there's a certain number of users where
in the network where the the sort of
average utility provided for to each
each user relative to the status quo
becomes compelling and then it takes off
right you hit that parabolic phase and
then it levels off right that it looks a
lot like the network function yeah and
but but and and so you have the
bootstrapping phase problem with with
everything that has network effect and
that's like how do I get to a million
users five million users 20 million
users where you get to that compel
utility for each user relative to the
status quo and what the crypto asset
does is it allows speculators to stand
at t0 look out into the future and make
a bet about what that utility may be one
day if enough people come to the
technology to use it and by standing
there at t0 and making a bet in the
future they those speculators are able
to receive financial utility today and
that financial utility provided today
makes up for the bootstrapping phase and
they literally pull a technology into
existence via speculation that is super
revolutionary dude that was one of the
big reasons I quit my job when I
understood how that worked I was like I
got it I got it that's you've never seen
anything like that before ever yeah the
only the only analogy I can even think
of it it's completely different is this
idea of with with Facebook so I forget
the exact time time time I set up but it
was like you know you had to get 10
friends at first 14 days when we joined
Facebook and so what phase when Facebook
realized this what they saw was just
getting a Facebook account you had X
percent chance to stay as a retained
user over some period of time if you've
got three friends in two days what X
percent plus you know whatever and they
eventually realized that you know it's
called eighty percent of all users if
they get ten friends in 14 days they're
gonna stay for you know a year whatever
it is and so they sort of drive towards
that metric and so you joined Facebook
you got no friends they just inundate
you you know give us all your contacts
your email right do you know this person
you know that suggestions I mean just is
overwhelm you until you start connecting
people the second you hit that 10 and 14
days BAM they back off let you enjoy
Facebook right the data shows them the
lock and is there and and that network
is gonna pull you along to be a user I
think that you know kind of social
networks is very very different than the
technology which I want digital asset
side there's some comparisons or
analogies but the idea of on with money
right or economic value it's like
everything that these social networks
did right and we did four years on
steroids on a global basis yeah right
and it's just I think that's what's
pulling so many of these great minds in
it's just it's a whole new puzzle it's a
whole new game it's global and nobody
has figured it out yet yeah and the
first groups to figure it out or going
to not only personally a profit but they
are going to create inflection points of
the technology that are gonna be
groundbreaking so that's the thing
that's actually as a guy that
searching really hard for evaluation
methodology I got super fired up about a
modified Metcalfe's read everything
that's ever been written about it
talked to like professors and [ __ ] like
that and and started building my own
frameworks around it and the I think the
issue is that and what really got me
fired up is that the net ID function
accurately representing monthly active
user growth to revenue growth for 10
cent and Facebook that's what really I
was like man this could really be the
answer but the introduction of
speculation I think may make a modified
metcalfe approach just not really work
because this the speculative aspect of
it introduces the reflexivity that we've
seen and that's a function of the
velocity characteristics of speculators
versus users and like that's all I'm not
we can't really find velocity I'll just
I'll just say it's totally a massive
thing and crypto every once in a while I
run across people that say it's not a
thing they're literally wrong it is
totally a thing and it's in the velocity
characteristics of the speculator I
think may get in the way of modified
Metcalfe's acting the way it would in a
in a like in a social network setting
right because I'm not I'm not out there
gambling with like my facebook users
right like that kind of thing and so
that's unfortunate for most case yeah
yeah absolutely
so all right so let's talk about up till
today
right so 2018 we're filming this and
September of 18 let's talk about price
action from January 1st through eighteen
Center eighteen we just saw 20,000 a
Bitcoin right at end of the year and all
sudden we get this huge 70 18 a percent
draw down across digital assets what's
going on yeah so it's a number of things
and it's kind of an aggregate like it's
like it's like we're down whatever
bitcoins down 70% off the high if you're
down like 85% off the high a lot of
these tokens are down 90 plus percent
off their highs how do we get there and
it's really it's really an amalgamation
of relatively I think kind of unrelated
things
that in aggregate sort of came to that
one you had just a blow off top in late
2017
yeah price of Bitcoin went from fifty
eight hundred to twenty K and thirty
four days bro thirty you need normal
four days
fifty-eight hundred to twenty thousand
right and completely unsustainable I'm
not probably one of the most epic price
movements of the last hundred years no
ever in any instrument ever anything
nuts yeah and and so you had to back a
lot of that out and yeah and and the
price action got so drastically far out
in front of its keys relative to where
the tech was right top hundred aggregate
market cap tapped out at like eight
hundred and thirty billion dude eight
hundred and thirty billion it's a wild
wild and because that what is it that's
like one-eighth the size of the cold
market yeah right yeah and and the text
not even remotely close what's nine you
remotely close to being ready right
nobody using any of this stuff for
anything right so you had to back a lot
of that out and then you've had all
these regulatory updates as well too and
the US has actually been I would say
less heavy-handed than feared but
there's a lot of like regulatory things
over and you have you got China banning
all kinds of stuff you've like India has
been super heavy-handed right I mean the
US regulators in my opinion have
probably been one of the best regulatory
bodies across the globe dealing with
this if you told me in 2016 as all this
was really starting to pick up steam
that we were gonna be sitting in you
know mid 2018 and they weren't gonna
have really clamped down on anything
other than the people who like
egregiously violated a law around fraud
market manipulation all that kind of
stuff I probably wouldn't believe you
right and so they've allowed a lot of
things to go on that were part of their
learning process yeah right and really
seeing hey what do people want to do
with this how does innovation evolve and
and I think that they don't get enough
credit for that but now they're getting
to the point where they're saying hey we
got to figure this stuff out we got to
get some rules out there so the
uncertainty goes away now people can
really start to build businesses right
in the United States and they're not
kind of just you know looking for a
regulatory arbitrage here and right but
there's been enough sort of globally
things happen from a regulatory
perspective that it's been a net
negative the uncertainty how things are
gonna get treated it's been a net
negative it's weighed on on prices lack
of institutional great infrastructure
totally a thing right like there's the
me mean like back half of 2017 it like
2018 like all the institutional money's
gonna come into space right that's all
they're all gonna it's like how like
literally how yep Fidel are you gonna go
buy a hundred billion dollars with a
Bitcoin and like throw it on a treasure
and like keep it in a filing cabinet
Abigail Johnson's office yeah yeah you
know I'm like how are they literally
going to do that you don't have any of
the the major investment banks like I
can't handle custody
you know the firm's that are handling
kustanai take massive flows right like I
mean we use big go for custody but like
if somebody's trying to do like a
hundred billion and big go like they
can't handle it
right yeah and and also the institutions
that are building it today I really do
think that they're looking at it it's
kind of like a commercial bank looks at
a bank account right so if I build
custody if I'm you know JP Morgan
Goldman whoever if I bought custody and
I get you to use my custody solution now
I can sell you all of my services
trading etc around that custody service
yeah it is the kind of the Trojan horse
to customer stickiness right and so I
think that not only do they need to
build it for themselves because that's
where they're gonna trust that's what
they're gonna actually use but then also
from it's a huge customer acquisition
benefit yeah and so if they can build
this stuff the way that they're talking
about building it it may be the saving
grace right it may actually give them
kind of a foothold into the market that
allows them to really play as real
players yeah I mean we'll get there I
mean they're throwing so many people and
dollars and resources at solving all
this image trucks are problem dozens of
projects trying to do it right you know
so it'll get solved it's just not here
in 2018 so prices have been going down
and then like volatility killed the
store value thesis in the near term
right there is that meme as well too
right people thought it we're just gonna
rock it up to like $50,000 BTC and then
just hang out there and you're gonna
have like wallah digital gold yep like
anything that goes up 14x in a year and
down 65 percent in a hundred days is not
a store value yet people are speculating
that maybe one day will become a store
of value that it's not yet and then like
in the meantime it's
or waking up to that and like you're not
gonna buy a cup of coffee with Bitcoin
anytime soon either I just didn't really
make that much sense to do that well in
time horizons matter right so if you say
hey I need a store of value for the next
year yeah probably not that attractive
but actually not attractive at all right
if you're saying hey look I want to
store a high percentage of my net worth
in this over the next 10 20 years yeah
now all of a sudden you look at it a
little bit differently or your
perspective changes on you know what is
your belief of the future store of value
properties correct yeah and then and so
it's like in the near term BTC not
really working as an sov or an mo II and
then so that's her price is year-to-date
and then like here come the stable coin
parade - right right and you're like oh
that's how we're gonna buy a cup of
coffee a decentralized stable coin and
it's not just shady teather either right
and it's like you think it's backed up
one two one two dollars whatever like
the director of the FBI like said it was
like okay I'm sure I'm like whatever
happened in the past like so that's my
whole thing is if at this point it's not
right just I mean absolutely you know go
back to word [ __ ] right if people
have been speculating on this for how
long and then all sudden somebody goes
to check today and it's not backed up
it's just complete stupidity yeah yeah
and and you know obviously with all the
fund teather it's still like the eighth
the eighth largest crypto by market you
like 3.3 billion dollars a market cap in
it or something like that and so
obviously there's a really strong need
for something like that so they're you
know all kinds of people trying to solve
that problem and you're getting it like
it's like what do you got like
andreessen horowitz it's like throwing
down hard on a Bain Capital Ventures
throwing down hard on it like all these
exchanges throwing down hard on it and
so I mean what the biggest raise is
probably uh Nader and the basis yeah
that's right so there's like 130 million
or something from the entries in Spain's
etc of the world and then you've got on
the other end of the spectrum you've got
the gem and I kind of regulated dollar
stable coin they didn't raise any
outside capital as far as I know right
and so it's two very different
approaches once an algorithmic Central
Bank the other is a you know we're going
all-in on the existing laws regulations
you know Wall Street etc the scary part
or maybe I'm scared just the interesting
part is both could win they could
coexist
okay right there's no there's no kind of
binary one has to wind one has to lose
here which makes it even more
interesting yeah
yeah so we'll see we'll see how that
plays out right but I but I think that's
the introduction of the concept of a
decentralized stable core Negus hurt BTC
prices year-to-date
because like if you're a Venezuelan
farmer like you know you sold your life
savings into BTC at like 19 K right well
what you really wanted was like US
dollar if you really wanted like a
stable coin that's like tied of the US
dollar or whatever and so so we'll see
how that plays out but it certainly hurt
prices here today and then also you've
had this this focus on valuation and
specifically token structure and like
token structure in the context of value
capture and like there was there was
sort of a general thought in 2017 that
like these icos
like if more people come to this
technology the price of the token is
going to go up and it's not that simple
right and you know the vast many many
many moons also what every Ponzi scheme
believes as well many many many of the
like 16 17 early 18 vintage I cos a
token structure is fundamentally flawed
in its ability to crew value over the
long term yeah and people didn't realize
that then because nobody was talking
about valuation and what really happened
what really happened was I think was
Chris pernitskiy wrote crypto assets
which it like a year ago literally a
year ago he wrote that book top and
probably a top 5 recommended book in the
space yeah if your introductory you got
to read it if and he and he throughout
MV equals PQ and the people got super
fired up about in vehicles PQ and then
like 60 days after they got really fired
up you were like this doesn't work at
all for ABC reasons which were valid
reasons yeah but what it did do was it
shined a spotlight on the velocity
problem and people were like ah there's
this thing called velocity all else
being equal the faster token spins to
the ecosystem the lower the price needs
to be for that token to satisfy the
economic demand of the ecosystem as a
whole and we don't in like it's not
something you plug into a model it's not
you don't you don't use it like that but
you just know directionally if this
thing if people don't if there's not an
if the mechanism design isn't such that
people want to hold it or have to hold
it
or there you have to stake it where you
can't you can't move it for a while or
you know whatever reasons if there's a
tendency to move it really fast it's
gonna have a hard time accruing value
over the long term and that was kind of
like year today people have woken up to
that and so you've just seen this big
drain a market cap specifically out of
you know BTC dominance has been rising
for four and a half months now you've
gone from I think like these 7% yeah I
think you've gone in a straight line
from like 34% to like 58% or whatever
over the last four and a half months the
market is obviously telling you
something there and you know we when I
think about it when I think about like
what's a bottom and this market gonna
look like we're we all right so slow
that's year-to-date let's go outlook
right so are we at the bottom and if not
where are we going yeah so I like to
look at Norfolk gratz called the bottom
he says that he says we hit the bottom a
week ago or a couple days ago what do
you think no grass is a nice guy no no
comment there shoutouts David namtar to
people like amber I love me our he's
he's one of the best all right so where
we going so so so on coin market cap I
like looking at top hundred aggregate
market cap minus BTC okay which I call
bottom 99 market cap yep that number
peaked that in the first week of January
at 547 billion dollars which is a wild
that is an outlandish lehigh number when
you think about as like one fourteenth
of the gold market yeah for by the way
99 of those tokens majority of the world
couldn't name a single one of no no yep
oh oh and nobody's using any of this
[ __ ] for anything because it sucks great
and there's 27 tokens that have 400
daily active wallets just saw that stat
like a week ago that's a wild stat in 27
tokens with 400 folks that care at all
about this thing and so so that so that
we don't win mood when mood right so
that so that number currently is 89
billion for the bottom 99 so went from
we say 542 542 8 to 89
but 89 just takes you back to the first
week in November yep
so [ __ ] was still super wild before then
right everybody everybody was that right
like it
summer is summer 2017 was still super
well that the barbers the taxi drivers
they were all talking about it in first
we get Movember yeah exactly
and so so if I just go back and look at
where that number was you know for
example in chill on July 17th and number
was 36 billion in the first week of
September 15th that number was 50
billion yep so so I kind of used that
number to triangulate where where a
bottom might be because it's actually
easier for me to think about what
everything below Bitcoin should probably
be worth I mean you're talking about a
you know 50 to two-thirds drawdown to go
from here right yeah yeah yeah so so I
saw actually I actually think there's a
good chance I'll put it this way I think
it would be healthy for the space for us
to get cut in half again from here on
the bottom 99 yep like top hundred minus
BTC we look at so then you control so
then you triangulate that number the
bottom 99 with BTC dominance and then
I've got a chart that I've been looking
at for months now where that and then
that backs you into what BTC price is
gonna be and so I you know we won't hold
it to you but what was directional where
you think we're going you know again
technical analysis is like not the
end-all be-all at all yeah this would be
like the first quintile bottom in like
the history of ta like that's not how ta
works like that like a number doesn't
get tested five times and then like it
holds it's just like not really how it
works so you know what you're talking
about here is you know let's call it the
fifty eight fifty if 58 59 whatever it
is right basically knocking at the door
we've knocked four times right and if we
kind of stay at you know the 6500 number
whatever when we go back down these are
the fifth is the sixth the seventh
however many times we're gonna knock at
the door eventually door opens we fall
yeah right yeah and it's gonna be a
function of getting dragged down by that
bottom ninety nine when it went when
Arthur hey is the founder of bit Mex
introduced the etherium perpetual swap
he had a blog post called aetherium the
the double-digit [ __ ] coin and etherion
was trading it like I don't know like
four hundred eighty three are three
three something off a cliff on what 180
161 161 on the bottom and they and I
mean you want to talk about a dead cat
bounce so we've seen over the last
couple of days like that's kind of the
definition of a dead cat bounce we've
gone from 160 to like 250 right yeah and
now we're sitting right now there it's
so like I think we do I think we do
probably go see 100 yes and 100 a
theorem and then and that puts you at in
B's that puts you at NBS for aetherium
and then you start backing into like
okay whereas ripple gonna be ripple like
literally not it like not a functional
token right yep we all know that Bitcoin
cash like by the way the ripple army
loves when people come on here and talk
really highly of ripple shoutouts Brian
silk is going on listen here's why I
respect the hell that guy is because he
doesn't just talk about it on a podcast
he says listen Brad Garlin houseware
yeah let's let's let's just talk about
it we'll film it let people to decide
what they want to decide after that and
so you know look it there's nonzero
chance he's right nonzero chance that
he's wrong do you think he would be the
first to admit that I actually tend to
think that the the ripple crew is is
doing what they believe to be best right
I don't think that they're you know how
maliciously trying to you know screw
over or whatever so I'd love to see that
conversation because I actually think
that there would be points scored on
both boards Yeah right so so as a like
I'm agnostic in my view so I don't fall
in love with any of this [ __ ] and I
don't fall in hate with any of it either
yep and I think it's really hard to be
short ripple here because I think the
senior folks a triple realize that their
token you don't need it for X rappin yep
and they and now they know that the
whole world knows that and so at anytime
they could introduce new functionality
on X rappin where then you you you need
or like you like kind of you introduce
this new concept where XRP like like
there's some compelling reason for it to
exist in the context of X wrapping and
that thing I'll hit that would be the
quickest five bagger you've ever seen in
your life - totally right well because
what you're talking about here is
there's like price action and
you know there's ta there's some of the
fundamental stuff whatever and then
there's just these wild cards in this
market where the the I don't anyone call
price manipulation as much as just like
the ability to evolve the code and the
the kind of structure around these
tokens in a knight and completely change
the landscape is unseen in almost any
other financial market in the world
right right you can't if you're Facebook
you can't say hey we had you know
whatever four and a billion dollar
market cap and we did you know forty
billion or whatever they're doing on
revenue and overnight oh by the way now
we're doing a hundred billion right
right this doesn't happen yeah and so
the the difference here though is you
know revenue is it necessary driving the
token price and so it could be literally
how it's used you changed overnight BAM
almost like a completely different
ballgame and we're going up you know 5x
especially for a lot of these utility
tokens right where people we've realized
that the initial token structure just
doesn't accrue value over the long term
and so the way the way that a tikka guy
the way that we like break up the world
is you kind of think about your web 3.0
stack but then I think about and we
consider the top hundred fifty criminals
by market camp is our universe that's
the those are the tokens we collect data
on do analysis on watch everything yep
you have the tokens that are vying to be
store value bitcoins obviously leading
that I put Bitcoin cash in that bucket
all the privacy tokens come on that
bucket D Craig goes in that bucket and
the the value the value framework that
you put those is its own separate beasts
right because it's like it really is
like that Austrian economics type of
framework right and it's like hard money
versus soft sound versus unsound and and
and that's the kind of framework you put
around store value and then then you
have the platform level protocols so
like smart contract platforms dab
platforms name of rail platforms like
aetherium IO stellar Cardno
cue them are chain icon I know I forgot
some other ones in there right but you
get the point right and the the value
proposition for those they're a function
of the activity that happens on top of
them right you don't write any etherium
smart contracts at three maher worth
anything right
you don't know payments going through a
stellar like it's not worth anything and
and so you think about the value
proposition for those as a function of
like how have they built the specific
sort of way that they
you talk about the scalability trilemma
right like like like how many
transactions gonna do how secure is it
how decentralized is it you know where
do they set those levers to be the best
home possible for the type of activity
they're trying to draw on to that
network and like the the analogy that I
use is like when you make your own
character like on NBA 2k right like if
he if he if he's if he's like got really
good hops like he may not play defense
that well or like if he's a great passer
like he probably doesn't dunk that way
yeah when I'm looking for all-nba
offense or on the defense we're looking
just for all-nba right and so you gotta
set the levers at a certain point to be
attractive to that certain type of
activity to come on top of it so that's
those evaluation frameworks then you got
utility tokens specifically within
utility tokens you got productive
utility took is in non-productive
utility tokens productive utility tokens
are like work tokens and that's like
auger and numeraire where you can
actually model those and you can model
them in the same way that I used to do
like a DCF on like a like a like a
company everybody up and so the the the
valuation framework do you think about
those actually kind of looks like like
the real world so it's easier to get
your head around how to think about what
those look like then that leaves you
with non-productive utility tokens those
are the ones we haven't figured out yet
and but what we do know generally
speaking is that like mo e tokens they
don't accrue value over the long term
like if you're just a Chucky Cheese
token like you know I'm like yeah you
can't put quarters in the in the video
game right you got to take your five
dollar bill you put in the machine you
get I'll check your cheese tokens put
the chucky cheese tokens in video game
but like when you're done playing chucky
cheese like you don't want to hang
around the chucky cheese tokens you give
me my your quarters back right you know
do not accrue value over the long term
that's a big problem for many of the
1617 early 18 vintage icos but the
problem is also this is like this is the
whole thesis around inflationary
monetary supply right is that actually
what they're doing is they're trying to
incentivize you to spend to not hold on
to the cash because it loses value every
single year as inflation it yeah and so
the deflationary model is the exact
opposite right this whole idea of store
value but whatever but on the
inflationary side what we're seeing is
the if we want you to spend the price is
artificially depressed because of the
downward pressure right like it like
like it is right it is intentionally
there
because that's how the structure becomes
and so it's a really bad speculative
investment if you are trying to go long
on the value of the token yeah and and
and you know you can we can keep going
as far as you know you can go really far
down that in terms of like what do you
need decentralization for yep in that
specific instance in like in many cases
like don't tokenize like it's it's it's
not a good idea for you and you like but
but but for utility tokens
non-productive utility tokens we haven't
figured out how to make the token
structure accrue value over the long
term and so but at some point you're
gonna figure it out I mean the ecosystem
will figure it out to be smart people
yeah and and then I think you could see
a situation where if you've got a
compelling piece of technology or a use
case that exists today and then but the
token structure doesn't work and it's
out there you know down 95 percent
year-to-date if somebody goes and
figures out the token structure and
another token you may see just this
massive swath of restructuring of token
structures and then they're like oh look
we fixed it and it works better now you
know like come use our technology it's
hard to say how all that stuff's gonna
play out but it's really scary if you're
a long or a short you don't know it's
coming yeah right yeah I think it's hard
to make money on the short side in this
space absolutely all right so let's do a
rapid fire here what do you think is the
most controversial thing you believe in
crypto right so like something you
believe to be true that you think a very
high degree of other people would
disagree with you on the bottom 99 it's
probably gonna get cut in half from here
before we bottom yep in Bitcoin the
relationship to Bitcoin there is you
think it's get dragged out 50 percent as
well or no it's gonna hang in but it's
gonna hang in better though I mean it's
really it's really really hard to say
I'll just say that in that scenario it's
hard for me to imagine that fifty eight
fifty holds is little oh yeah yeah I
think it's fair I think there's a lot
disagree with you usually other part of
this whole idea around like price action
and and you know where's the bottom all
the stuff that we were talking about
I've never seen a market where there was
bull bear you know kind of
cycle that turned over and people still
remember the bull market and you hit the
bottom right right like from a
psychological standpoint if you go on
Twitter right now people literally think
we're going to 20 30 40 50 thousand
dollars by the end of the year yeah
right and it's just I can't believe that
you know there's no blood in the street
and we're gonna turn it around right and
so like I came out and I said this and
people all freaked out you know oh
you're like switching your mentality
around all this and I was like wait
there's just not enough pain yet yeah
and and when the pain gets really really
bad and we're gonna walk away we're
gonna say this is over right that's when
I think you know we are at least near
the bottom but we haven't seen that yet
yeah I mean I was an energy investor for
seven years right like I've seen some
major league chopped in markets before
and like if what we just had was the
bottom I'm gonna have to rewrite my
understanding of what bottoms look like
like I'm just being honest man you know
I'm so willing to be wrong and I'll do
it I'll text you when that happens I'll
text you I'll be like I think I might
have been wrong yep I'll text and then
you can tweet it out like fanboys all
right so what do you think is the most
interesting or important company encrypt
other than what you're working on
I love the rapid-fire gets the pauses
and answers every time I'm not gonna
name anybody specifically I'm gonna say
anyone working on mechanism design and
tinto constructor anybody like it's like
I know some I got it's like somebody's
in token foundry yep it consensus like
consensus is like it's kind of a mess
right and everybody knows that like I
got some guys in there they're like
crazy smart shoutout Rocco
you know Rocco right and and like
anybody doing that kind of work digging
deep on like where's the video game
designers at man where are those guys at
how are you not in this space Yeah right
where's my where's my Harvard ph.d
mechanism design guy what's he doing
this is the girl listen I keep going
back to this idea of so that people who
worked on growth it was the badges it
was the streaks it was the you know all
of the points and tokens and all this
crazy stuff that we've been doing for
years are now tied to a value that can
be traded it is all of that design onst
100% oh by the way I'm gonna I'm gonna
retract my to my most controversial
thing okay
FOMO 3d one of the best things that ever
happen in crypto you gotta explain it
again complete scam literally a Ponzi
scheme the the regulatory little the
little drop down like when you click
through it on like the regulations it
takes you directly to the SEC website
for definition of Ponzi scheme it's like
the the websites called exit scam calm
yeah two months before I heard about
FOMO 3d we were talking internally about
how we're gonna figure out this this
token structure problem for the
non-productive utility tokens and I said
I was like when we get it figured out
it's gonna look like this gimmick and
it's gonna look like this little like
this little thing and when people see it
they're gonna be like that's [ __ ]
but it is but it's gonna work and people
gonna like wait is that is that like a
like that shouldn't work but it's gonna
work anyways right and then the next
thing you know it's gonna skyrockets I'm
talking to a hundred billion because it
had that that hook from mechanism
designed to like lock in naturality
and the economically juice network
effect in a in a way their cruise value
over the long-term
FOMO 3d again not supporting it but I'm
saying that concept abstracted into part
of a utility tokens design could very
well end up being the key that unlocks
the the value accrual the people who
figured out growth hacking for the
centralized internet one one the people
who figure out growth hacking in the
decentralized world will win by
magnitudes more in fact right I mean
it's just gonna be it's gonna be
fascinating alright so you've got a
magic wand you can wave it change one
regulation what do you change we're not
doing this with the Howey test you're
doing it with something else okay oh so
on the security side resident by seán
security what do you think needs to get
put in there that like what like what is
the the new one look like what are some
other components that aren't there that
maybe you think there should be there
where are we too early we can't tell
coming you're just you're using your
user a piece of regulation that was it
was Judas
Shoal precedent that was set with the
staff 1933 establish think it was I
don't remember but I know it was about
orange trees orange groves in Florida
like that's the law that we're gonna use
to govern magic internet money about
Florida orange groves like they just
doesn't make any sense right so if I
could pull anything back then you'd get
a new law specifically about this so
it's not it's not getting rid of it
completely it's just saying look we need
something new yeah we still need a test
it's just what it looks like we need to
figure it out the regulators have a
bunch more opinions in and who knows
maybe they're gonna end up there trying
to like you know shoehorn whatever like
round round hole square peg this thing
to making it work and that you know
what's-his-name Hinman introduced the
concept of like sufficient
decentralization and they're like
literally gonna just like try and layer
that on top of a rule about Florida
orange trees like sufficient
decentralization okay all right listen
is the orchard decentralized all right
so one non crypto question
look everyone loves aliens right Twitter
goes nuts when I talk about all this
alien stuff and I recently had the
thought of out of everything people have
thought about on the alien side do
aliens have pets right so are there you
know we always think of aliens it's like
this equivalent to humans right they're
gonna you know have some level of
intelligence they're gonna kind of look
like us generally they're gonna kind of
walk and talk and communicate and do all
this activity but we never think about
on that on the animal side right so one
animal aliens and then two is do they
have pets they are they showing up with
you know some sort of equivalent to dogs
and cats or what's going on there I just
try and draw from like precedent
transactions on this one and it's like
I'm I look at Schumacher right and like
I was like basically like a really
really dope pet right yeah thank right
yeah yeah if you have like sovereign
rights Chewbacca
I don't know about that I don't know
anyways like I'd take a Chewbacca right
now so I figure that if you're an alien
like that's probably higher that's what
you're all your own over the Chewbacca
I've not heard that answer yet
alright so I'll let everyone to close it
out ask me one question what a question
you get what still I hadn't caught up
with you in a while like we're like what
Morgan Creek what's y'all's like what's
the next like six to 12 months look like
for Morgan Creek we are running around
and banging her head against the wall to
get every single institution of zero so
if you think of your if your institution
you've got no exposure to you know what
is the probably the best performing
asset class over the last five years
there's a bunch of data that shows if
you take a 60-40 global portfolio put 1%
of digital assets you get a anywhere
between 150 to 300 basis point you know
increasing returns depending on when you
did it and you get a near identical
standard deviation of risk you get a
double-digit increase in Sharpe ratio
and we actually specifically for BTC
digital assets is defined in a whole
bunch different ways if you some people
done which is Bitcoin so we have done
top tens top 5 etc it just generally or
deletes directionally where it ends up
our argument is that if you are one of
let's take a pension fund for example
you're at the Duty's feature payout so
you got a future obligation to fund you
know all of your pension plan recipients
your actuary comes in and says hey
you've got a six seven eight percent
assumed rate of return so in order for
you to payout in the future you have to
hit six seventy percent whatever your
specific plan is most of them are
unperformed or underperforming that and
so if you look out over the next ten
years around stocks bonds currencies and
commodities it's not gonna get you there
right kind of with the traditional asset
classes and so I know me so I think you
should go for one hundred percent of
your assets in digital but what I do
think that you should do is you should
start to get some of the digital asset
exposure because what it shows is not
only does it keep the risk profile very
similar volatility you know everything
is attracted there but you start to
drive a higher return and so that
conversation is very very different than
like by Bitcoin because it's gonna be
the global reserve currency it's taking
the crypto ethos and argument and
speaking in a language that the
institutions understand and you know
look I'm new to the institutional world
and so obviously more Creek's been a
huge advantage and getting us in the
room and having these conversations and
it helps to have you know folks like
Marc usko who's got this long track
record to be one of the people saying
this and what I found is they're
incredibly receptive they're not as
receptive to the bitcoins new store
about you visual gold kind of
when I consider more than qualitative
arguments the quantitative argument of
you have to hit seven percent in order
to fulfill your future obligations
you're not gonna do that with a current
asset lasas this is a semi uncorrelated
asset and if you put some allocation
here we will get you closer yeah it's
just a data it's a data argument right
and so I think that we're making inroads
there and you know we'll announce much
stuff over the next couple weeks but I
think that for the next at least 12
months I mean that that is the campaign
it is get off zero I can't tell you what
the right percentage is per portfolio
maybe's ten basis points 5,200 but I
don't know you can look at each one but
you know what do you put them in so we
literally say to them look you've got a
whole bunch of different capital pools
so you've got your equity you've got
your debt real estate fixed income
whatever it is we're building a bunch of
products that allow them to pick and
choose so if you've got an equity bucket
and you're only you know you got 10% of
your allocation for equity you're only
eight percent deployed that means you've
got 200 basis points that you can
actually go and buy some equity so let's
get some percentage of that into the
equity bucket maybe your fully deployed
on the equity side so you've got a debt
bucket you've got some under deployment
there hey let's get make sure we've got
a debt product and so building different
products we actually think that I'm a
digital asset site people gonna build
portfolios they're not gonna go you know
you never go hundred percent cash you
never go one percent into one real
estate strategy so they're gonna build
this very multi strategy approach or
kind of portfolio construction in the
digital world now here's the
counterintuitive piece of this and I've
thought a lot about it in so take the US
dollar 19 you know 70s you know and
before hundred percent paper notes right
today 92 percent supply is not paper now
right so we've already had the
digitization of a currency over time the
u.s. dollar is probably the first
digital currency that majority of
Americans have interacted with right
because it's just 90 percent right and
so if you look at that Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies natural currencies are
just another evolution of that and then
if you look at stocks for example used
to be all paper right then went to
electronic trading today if you invest
in a private company most people are
actually digitally signing for the
documents they're receiving it through
Carta a shares you know angellist
whatever they have an electronic or a
digital version of that stock
certificate right and so the idea that
you're gonna have a token in your
digital wallet is just another
evolution of that technology so what
does that mean for like cow for
alligators well Robin Hood is actually a
great example of somebody who has built
asset management capital allocation in a
digital world
so it's targeted digital natives it's
got a fee structure that looks very
attractive it allows you to buy these
digital electronic public equities and
now they've added crypto currencies in
there as well well if all sudden
tokenization of real estate becomes real
will they allow you just to hold your
shares of real estate in the same wallet
probably right it's just it's just an
evolution and so you know when you start
having that conversation with these
institutional investors I think that
they they're generally like my kids
telling me this right you know my twenty
to thirty year old son or daughter is
pounding the table and saying hey this
is real I'm interested in this whatever
that's a little ways away though from
like hey here's a hundred million
dollars Yeah right and it is I think
that's like next twelve months we're
gonna see a couple of those checks get
laid down and when they get laid down I
think the dam breaks and game on musical
chairs yeah it did for real all right
man the super fund by the time and he'll
that will get you on here again Cheers